oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre guillaume garot chers collègues
alors que le salon mondial vinexpo se
tient à bordeaux cette semaine où je
vous ai rencontré monsieur le ministre
lundi je suis élu de la gironde
viticulteur et président du groupe
d'étude de la vigne et du vin du sénat
je suis inquiet je dois dire très
inquiet en effet à la suite à la
décision de la commission européenne de
lutter contre le dumping chinois sur les
exportations de panneaux solaires
l'europe à les surtaxer la chine
envisage des mesures de rétorsion sévère
sous les exportations européennes devint
en particulier la france premier
fournisseur avec un million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et 140 millions de
litres vendus en 2012 pourrait subir de
plein fouet ce qui n'est pas encore une
guerre commerciale mais qui pourrait le
devenir bordeaux est le principal veut
importer en chine avec 20% de sa
production café la commission européenne
les panneaux solaires chinois se voient
imposer des droits de douane hauteur de
11 80% depuis le 6 juin 2013 ils
passeront en 47 % le 6 août prochain si
aucun accord n'est trouvé avec la chine
d'ici là le commissaire européen
espère bien avoir une soixantaine de
jours pour parvenir à une solution
négociée
je trouve que c'est bien long quelles
sont les mesures envisagées par la chine
immédiatement elle annoncé l'ouverture
d'une procédure d' enquête antidumping
et antisubventions sur les vins importés
en provenance union pn nous avons d'un
bordelais la preuve formelle que
certains importateurs chinois et je
voulais rappeler monsieur le ministre
lundi ont déjà pris des mesures
coercitives qui se concrétise par des
noms expédition de conteneurs de 20 en
chine nous savons qu'il n'ya pas de
dumping sur les vins européens des
subventions à la production de vin en
france comme en europe oui la france
l'union européenne respecte les règles
de l'om s'est en revanche les sixièmes
les chiliens sont en train d' abaisser
leurs droits de douane pour prendre les
parts de marché en parallèle nous
prenons très au sérieux ce qui n'est
peut-être qu'une trace tj face à une
europe qui n'avance pas sur délais tout
comme les allemands ne souhaitons pas
une gradation et différents contentieux
un projet de réunion des 27 membres de
l'union européenne est évoquée par le
président de république en vue de
rapprocher les points de vue dans cette
négociation avec la chine qu en est-il
monsieur le ministre j'ajoute et j'en
termine que le désarroi actuel de la
filière vitivinicole risque d'être
aggravé par la fiscalité comportementale
sur le vin qui serait plus monétaire que
pédagogique
le groupe vigne et vin du sénat s'est
opposé à l'unanimité à cette proposition
dans le redressement de la fiscalité sur
le vin qui exprime ce qui pourrait
déstabiliser gravement la filière merci
des paroles est à présent monsieur
guillaume garot ministre chargé de
l'agroalimentaire merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur vous
l'avez dit la chine a ouvert une
procédure anti dumping et anti
subvention auprès de l' omc s'agissant
des vins européens et nous l'avons dit
avec stéphane le foll l'union européenne
communiquera toutes les informations
nécessaires pour répondre aux questions
posées par la chine comme le prévoit la
procédure mais je veux le dire à mon
tour le secteur ne reçoit pas dead
direct à l'exportation nos vins ne
bénéficient pas de des dos de subvention
de mesure donc de dumping les seuls les
seuls soutiens qui sont apportées
portent sur l'amélioration du vignoble
et sur la promotion des indications
géographiques et donc ce type de mesures
n'est pas de nature à distordre le
commerce international quoi qu'il en
soit l'europe ne doit jamais négliger sa
force de marcher et le poids qu'elle
pèse lorsqu'elle parle d'une voix unie
d'une voix cohérente c'est pourquoi et
vous l'avez rappelé le président de la
république a appelé à une convergence
des positions entre les 27 états membres
de l'union or monsieur le sénateur nous
comprenons bien évidemment les
inquiétudes de nos viticulteurs parce
que la chine est un pays où la présence
française est forte est importante mais
je veux le dire aussi ici ni l'europe ni
la france ni la chine n'ont intérêt à
une guerre commerciale nos différents
aujourd'hui ne porte que sur 1% je dis
bien un pour cent de nos échanges et
donc nous devons plus que jamais
privilégier la voie du dialogue un
dialogue que nous voulons approfondie
régulier et qui doit se traduire par une
discussion en permanence ouvert c'est ce
que nous ferons demain dans le cadre de
la commission conjointe union européenne
chine sur le commerce et l'industrie et
vous le savez en tout cas je vous le dis
ce dossier sera abordé
retenez une chose nous ne sommes pas
dans une logique de surenchère nous ne
sommes pas dans une logique d escalade
mais bien dans une logique de
transparence et soyez sûrs que le
gouvernement reste bien évidemment très
mobilisés très attentif très vigilant
mais en même temps tout à fait serein
sur l'issue de cette procédure je vous
remercie